bonjour et bienvenue dans le studio
diagonale tv aujourd'hui avec une
légende des échecs à saint-quentin
cinquantaine 2015 deuxième titre de
champion de france vétérans pour nicolas
giffard beaux jours nicolas bonjour
stéphane ortelli je disais une vraie
légende du jeu puisque tu es un des
premiers maîtres internationaux
deuxième le deuxième après l'opa hic
donc un des premiers et tu avais gagné
déjà deux championnats de france 78 et
82 et tu es aussi l'auteur de nombreux
best-sellers dans les échecs
ce gens n'ont rien ma famille la
fabuleuse histoire des champions
d'échecs le guide des échecs et moult
autres livres qui ont fait de toi
d'ailleurs un des spécialistes de
l'histoire du jour aussi oui mais je
peux en historien mais disons que j'aime
bien raconter les histoires à propos du
tournoi d'échecs et la psychologie les
champions du monde ce genre de chose
j'aime bien raconter mais je suis pas un
archiviste qui passe mon temps dans les
bibliothèques intentions non c'est
encore un autre nid pour ça il ya un
anglais qui s'appelle edward winter là
vous allez sur son site et on trouve
absolument aucune
inexactitudes parce que c'est un
historien pur et dur en moi je sais pas
dans ce style of style plutôt avancer
les choses
sans non plus éloignés trop de la
réalité et moi y voit la tête quand même
renseigné avant toi il y avait un autre
français je pensais déjà premier volume
lyon nice et saint françois le lensois
part d'entre eux soit lu le livre qui
est non il a préféré m'en de livres sur
l'histoire du jeu que je crois pas à ma
connaissance mais il a fait le
dictionnaire des échecs actionnaires en
collaboration avec quelqu'un qui
s'appelait ernst majid c'est un livre
des années 60 moi c'était mon livre de
chevet parce que ça mélangé le jeu les
problèmes les biographies des joueurs
et puis c'était très épais et donc jeu
c'était le livre idéal dans lequel
piocher avant de s'endormir
parce que c'était donc des entrées par
ordre alphabétique mais c'était pas un
livre qu'on avait a commencé puis à
finir en piocher dedans comme ça c'était
toujours intéressant toujours joli ce
qu'il y avait dedans et ça ça m'a donné
le goût du jeu
alors on parle alors donc des rites au
championnat donc on va avoir une beauté
par qui a fait la partie décisive alors
quitte à donner en février
mais avant ça tu vas nous raconter
comment ça s'est passé et alors pourquoi
aussi que tu avais déjà dernier sous
titre il ya un 2013 en 2013 par exemple
moi aussi je vais y aller avec un score
le même score que j'ai fait ici c'est
des scores inimaginable dans les autres
tournois 10h30 sur 11 mai la peau
sérieusement j'ai me suis retrouvé à la
10e ronde ayant déjà joué tous les
adversaires derrière moi au classement
et je suis allé piocher un adversaire
pour la 2e ronde qui avait deux points
moins que moi je croyais d'accord et
1790 et l'eau oui j'avais un point et
demi d'avancé dans le tournoi sur le
2ème donc j'étais sûr en gagnant c'est
la partie de la deuxième ronde même nul
lui suffisait non nul j'aurais eu un
point d avance pour la dernière ronde et
je pouvais me faire rattraper
ah oui dans quels impôts et demi
d'avancé il suffisait de gagner la
partie va bien pour être assuré et
j'avais un adversaire en face de moi et
c'était écrit 2790 points elo bon je me
suis dit à l'aise alors on va jouer
normal et puis la faute va venir et en
fait il est beaucoup plus fort ce joueur
que son héros l'indiquent
oui j'ai vu la partie d'ailleurs un
petit peu géré à dallas il plaçait les
petits prix
d'après l'ordinateur à un moment il
aurait pu gagner mais c'était un coup
difficile à trouver
on n'y a pas pensé l'élu nîmois ah oui
mais donc c'était beaucoup plus
difficile que connaît le laisser se
raser le classement est le premier coup
déjà il m'a surpris
alors parce qu'elle va évidemment dans
les banques de données n'y a rien c'est
un joueur qui est très peu et donc j'ai
pas pu trouver des exemples de son jeu
mais manque de données alors il m'a joué
au premier cours cavaliers c3 voilà
alors déjà oui enseignants surprise
c'est déjà ça
en levant le soja mais ce coup là parce
qu'en général on veut pas bloquer
pioncer il ya que dans l'histoire du jeu
il y avait un grand maître yougoslave
jouer ça systématiquement qui s'appelait
mais ce trop vite
je crois que c'est parce qu'il n'est pas
mort
dizaine alors le cours normal de ses
dessins qu'on peut pousser au 5 et alors
je veux que ça fait mal à se serrer
sylvain des quatre ils ont ils peuvent
plus jouer les gants voilà alors si les
blancs jouent des cats c'est ce qu'on
appelle une défense figurines à couleurs
inversées
mais il joue de quatre incitant les
noirs a poussé on doit bien connaître ce
système alors s'il est mort ou s'il est
mort ou les loges où leurs cavaliers à
eux deux ouais et sa pénible tu veux te
regarde non merci l'idée suivi de
détroit et ensuite de f4 voilà et les
blancs elle était bien où l'attaqué à la
loi donc j'ai pas voulu rentrer dans sa
spécialité je me suis dit que j'avais
bien aimé ça mais j'ai fait et puis on
prend pions
j'en tremble pion une principale alors
non j'aurais pu jouer c6 ou a aussi ceci
pour retomber sur le dos d'une
quarantaine ce que dans une française
est vrai mais bon j'ai pris me disant
qu' il fallait surtout pas de me taire
déjà joué des coups normaux simple et
puis un jour à 1790 va bien finir par
faire cavalier pour le cadre et
cavaliers 17 j'ai joué ses troupes dans
la variante de la carro kahn qui est
solide mr chirac alors ici youssoufou c4
alors lydie le cas et décès c'est quand
tu sors le cavalier en cas dé change up
il est remplacé aux romans etc 600w fous
ces cas ce qui est logique
alors déjà il faut que je fasse
attention parce que si je joue cavalier
gf 6 déjà ça fait super pour partie déjà
moi je perds une qualité il cet échec
rapport reprend cavalli gsm échec au roi
ou valleroy hainaut ce que j'ai par
exemple ces rois g6 ptt joie mais alors
laissé messi vient 8 et 10 8 et carla et
la donne est complètement emmuré voilà
aucune case et elle va se faire gober
par le cavalier au coup suivant voilà
ici et je joue au roi g8 et l'autre va
faire rage et si c'est pareil dans leurs
projets si c'est dans le sahara et au
même mois g8 enfin croire il ya
cavaliers aux six attaques la dame dames
8 obligé la dame est attaquée déjà on
est obligé de mettre la dame en voilà
une cabane et procès s'était alors
est-ce que le cac gagné 2 à 8 ce
ressortira plus tard je sais pas moi la
lettre affirmait je voulais pas qu une
partie comme ça avec les noirs systran
là il prend ici il ya des chiens pendant
une deux pions en plus ça me contait la
qualité sur palm
si vous voulez pas de fantaisie comme ça
je voulais jouer très sérieux et ça fait
peur j'ai joué le 6 voilà pour éviter le
cas il y est encore g8 sur tous ces cas
du jouet qui ça manque quand même un
tout petit peu plus 1 voilà
normal quoi il a joué dans me2 et oui
prépare sans doute des sacrifices en
russie je me suis ça marche pas dans la
position allongée février gm si ce n est
là il a fait cavalier 3 il n'est pas
venu enlever sa norvège parce que
j'aurais joué qu'à valider 6 à la
révéler bien presque qu'un gsm menaces
carey price n ont droit prend dans prend
aussi ses chéquiers matelas mais là je
vais jouer cavalier b6 attaque avec les
baissiers c'est le fou pour des jeux
voilà d'accord donc là il joue avec 33
j'échange
4 voilà d'un point à reprendre cavaliers
f6 londonienne temps sur la dame alors
s'il était venu en h4 là je rejoins
fouet cette c'est celui qui a pas dû lui
plaire dans l'hiver venu de fouet cette
tranquille et là je pensais qu'ils
allaient au lei a fait le rock oui voilà
mais aussi en crocs et là j'imagine et
des quatre oui ça pas la salir mon nom
il fait b3 non alors le maire que
c'était fait cavalier e 5 en fait pour
m'empêcher b6 parce que moi ma façon de
sortir l'info c8 la serbie s'il avait
joué cavalier ou 5 sur b6 ya
d'investissement à sa non il ya tout
simplement car il en sait 6 pour chef
d'alors donc sa mort est obligé à faire
des contorsions pour sortir mon souci
donc là il a joué b3g jouer b6 voilà et
là maintenant c'est trop tard pour faire
quelques simples alors il a joué qu il y
avait les cinq quand même de fouler
cette fougue et 2 femmes et 2 et là j'ai
joué dam des six dans des six il a joué
tour a des seins tout ça normal jouer tu
auras des milthon un des huit il fait il
se fout des droits fou des trois as
assez étonnant exactement ça c'est toi
non parce qu'il vienne devant son pion
oui mais il voulait aller attaquer h7
des cavaliers g4 son idée cessant de
jouer ensuite cavalier g4me pression sur
m6 ce soir là oui aussi comme le fou
catapulté
et puis derrière on sait jamais on est
un peu fou bon alors c'est une folie
j'ai commencé à prendre un petit
avantage en jouant d'amd 5 menace
m'attend ge a déjà tant des f4 ou f3 à
la rigueur à la tension dame est fou
angers ne les oui alors f3 mais le
problème si je mens 3 il sait qu'elle
est un peu il ça fait bien depuis plus
jamais il envisagera de faire coulisser
une tour aussi s'il veut attaquer voilà
c'est dit et ce rêve 4 il y avait
éventuellement pousser cinq échecs suivi
de fous des cas pour se changer et oui
il faut 6 5 échec puisque ou des quatre
en échange de fonds actuellement mais là
il a beaucoup réfléchi et les revenus
cavaliers f3 alors ça m'a donné
confiance je vais effectivement c'est
pas bon joueur c'est 8 796 personnes à
vis de vue d'un match sent qu'ici ouais
mais j'ai joué j'ai joué ici je peux pas
t'aider
oh
alors bon j'ai joué damage 5 disons
parce que c'est ça la position aille il
a joué à ce moment là tours est ce un
tournant
j'ai joué qu'avait cavaliers des cinq
arrêts clés des seuils menace de venir
en aide 4 voilà il fait damer 5
ouais mon asthme à tanger avant la
menace matongé cette dame h6 bonnafous
et 6 ou menacent maintenant foule si ça
voilà avec prise du four b2 alors il a
joué dame g3 donc dames chez 3 évite
cette manoeuvre en mai la dame à la
russie a quand même à faire coulisser
une pièce bourde devant le roi il vise
le roi comme un fou des six ouais faut
des six attaques la dame alors non voilà
il ya eu on a manqué deux couples ce que
mon option b 6 en fait se trouvant b4
actuellement à alors donc on va revenir
un peu parce que j'ai joué à un moment
de dessin alors c'était voilà comme ça
d'un match retour est fait maintenant
parce que lui il était revenue sous ces
quatre attaques madame alors remettre
debout avant d'accord ici ici ou alors
ici peut-être y fait pousser cadre au
lieu de quoi voulez de cabillaud 5
voilà ce que l'être le propos ici
ah non alors mais non mais les joueurs
qui avaient tout mais qui avait eu cinq
donc issifou b2 d'anne decis tu auras
des 1 j'aurais dit un taux de 8,8
il revient d trouverez la foulée d'un et
sa cavalière 3l qualif 3 à part
peut-être maintenant c'est proche de m
à 6 ou non pas six qu'est ce que tu
avais fait ainsi cinq tours 17 peut-être
maintenant partager ses licences par
deux
j'ai joué b5 en fait contre son fouet
dans ces cas et madame en âge cinq ans
et qu'il est revenu en c4 sa tour est en
alors comment on arrive à semer mais la
position remettre la position non remède
cavaliers lecavalier des finances des
cinq plus tard
donc il y avait le fou en c4 ici elle
fois en c4 alors il faut que je fasse
une édition de position ici donc le fou
ici et en c4 voilà là je joue b5 et ici
tu joues b5 tu me donne le temps de le
pion ouais c'est un faux seins c'est ça
va continuer hélas il a adoré la tour
eiffel fin par berson elle n'est pas
encore à la tour est enfin mis d'accord
c'est comme celà position à la fnac
orange ou b5 la ses traits au noir la
cour donc voyez que c'est du live un de
mémoire aulas est venu mais pas la
feuille de partisans la fin de partie et
on n'a pas pu et 5 1 voilà on a fait ça
en direct
voyez donc b5 ici ces îles proches il ya
un appareil 3 supra f3 est obligé de
faire jouer prenait froid et j'ai autour
des 5 ou des fous des six à sa cage de
voir même décalé des 5 es devenu un f4
donc il est revenue foot est roi donc il
revient en d3 et j'ai joué mes 4 et là
tu fixes ouais voilà pour fixer
intervenir plus tard dans la partie
d'accord léger toif centralise c'est
bien cavaliers des cinq ouais donc là
attention à nos cinq matchs du mona's
devenir un héros 24 voix la fedom cinq
mois ce matin jour à damas six dans la
crise
là il fait dames chez 3 parce qu'il y
avait la monnaie je joue au foot et 6
les six attaques à damas que la dame il
fait fou et 5
et là j'ai trouvé un bon cavalier des
cinq cavaliers ascap cavaliers extérieur
voilà ah oui alors donc aussi les blancs
prennent évidemment il ya le fouet la
dame
et oui ça c'est un coup quand on
n'imagine pas toujours par transparence
le cavalier fkt protéger et sa isole la
dame du fou à coire et puis en plus ça
vise la case g2 il ya le foot
leur live si c'est un coup logique il
neutralise mon fou bessette qui est
dangereux c'est fou 4 août à la ministre
voilà est là pour prendre l'aventage ça
a commencé à me perturber je savais pas
trop comment c'est tout à fait trois ans
maintenant c'est plus tard si tu ta en
lutte non
5 alors là je jouais tout à 6 pour pai
changement il faut six d'abord alors là
il y avait un coût intéressant et là qui
lui donne l avantage à un petit avantage
après l'ordinateur parce que je n'ai pas
poussé mon analyse assez loin ils
pouvaient faire froid en fourrages
séchés oui oui j'étais en train de le
voir effectivement sous price est parce
que c'est une dame prend cette fois le
carrément guérilleros apprend et
cavaliers g5 les ché ici on va prendre
cavale et gsm pour couper la dame à la
de la défense au crayonné après et après
on prend mais mon idée simplement le
cavalier je pensais que c'était pas à
redouter parce que sur fourrages cet
échec mon idée c'était de prendre avec
la dame s'est quand même malgré tout
voilà il prend un f4 je me suis dit et
je fais dame français de de la dame du
fou balle arrive à la l'ordinateur
montre qu'il peut faire dame prend 1,4
il prend l'avantagé parce que sur
d'hommes français 2 j'avais prévu ah oui
moi je vais là je me suis bien y est fou
prend des six est ensuite suivie dans le
premier cas t il ya un lien plus prendre
des six dames tour prend par exemple ou
ayants droit oui il ya le club des
quatre
bon là je dois avoir fait même des
décompensations parce que nous sommes
plus sûrs dans prend à 2,83 un ramasse
enfin tout cas où il crée des monts à
son ordinateur a montré sa d'accord donc
tous les deux on est logiquement et ça
nous a échappé pas facile à voir
voilà il a fait des trois la propre
parce que ma menace ses cavaliers eu
deux échecs sur fois ci oui il ya aussi
calé deux fourchettes 3 tôt et le fou à
6 contrôlent la place de donc detroit il
fait des trois ça bloque
ça bloque l'action du fou voilà et là je
fais f6 un bon coup parce que si ça fait
jouer mais tout prend des six obligé
mais parce que sinon il ya le film qui
attaquent la dame aux menaces cavani
échec on donne le cavalier s'est érodée
comprend d'amont voilà donc il faut
prendre le football à tour grand tour
prend donc je me suis pas trop peu
faibli parce que si c'est bien protégés
et matous l'idée c'est d'aller la
mettrons à cissé à la place du fou pour
ligue au belgradois la grâce au tube et
4 que tu qui qui justement tient en
respect cette chaîne de pions alors là
il fait cavalier d2 un coup qui m'a
montré qu'il était redoutable de se voir
là pour 1790 les coups et l'a donc beau
jeu pour savoir pourquoi il avait laissé
quatre pour aller au cio les uns c'est
clair puisque la libye aucune pions pour
l'attaqué éventuellement ou laurent
leucate a aussi gelé s'est déroulé en
quatre
donc là j'ai joué sous ses huit pour
bien défendre aussi ses adhérents à 6
avec ma tour donc défend le 6 et sai et
puis ça libère la classe à six mois la
boîte etc et par là donc ça lui a posé
un problème ça et il a beaucoup réfléchi
il a fait un coup de gueule
douteuses et je pense qu'il a mal joué
il a joué 63 s'est révélé très si
mauvais que ça donc j'ai joué tour à 6,3
en tout cas ils libèrent la tour sur le
pion à son idée aura 6 et tour quatre
attaques lecavalier cavani oui voilà 2,5
obligé déstabilise et on vous sent force
5 et tour pro b 4 prend le pion je le
vivrais tour prendra 2 juste à temps
pour les tours c4 oui il est fort et il
attaque confiance et cette voix là
défend le pion ces deux attaques c7 est
donc différent et guy stéphan 1790 il
veut pas donner titre nous avons donc là
j'ai fait plus fort c'est en fait c'est
tout à fait et je peux pas donner de
lancer cette c'est trop grave a défendu
pions alors voilà où l'ordinateur dit
qu'il allait manquer un gain de coups
plus tard la jeune cavalier ou 4 oui ça
m'a semblé un faux bon goût à cause de
f5 qui libère madame sur le 6ème
traverse et 100 des récents alors il
joue cavalier g5 à trac la tour ouais
c'est non mais là sans réfléchir j'ai
joué tous russell ordinateur indique
qu'il faut jouer absolument tour 17
tours 17
on se demande pourquoi ils sont recettes
pour ses habitudes ici
l'ordinateur dit qu'il ya un coût
ben oui d'accord est en fait les blancs
alors pour une avancée ni l'un ni
l'autre and on peut pas prendre pas de
tours en face ici mais on peut alors que
lecavalier en fait est presque en bas là
ils étaient stabilisés par des quatre
voilà ont ajouté quatre assists il
aurait dû jouer ça et à 20 heures
oui parce que là le 6e pions saute c'est
tout la position noir qui devient
fragile
il a fait un coup pour exploiter un peu
ma tour set il a fait tout repeint pour
avoir des combinaisons sur le clouage
sur la colonne olemps donc finalement
ils le voient pas fait tourner mais ça
me laisse un temps capitale pour
m'organiser j'ai une position dominante
après d'amd 6 d'une manière
décentralisée je protège tous essam
étage la tour parce qu'on sait jamais
alors voilà alors ici pour montrer que
c'est un joueur à 1790 atypique ça
posait un piège très très assez cash et
10 longs pour un joueur de ce niveau là
je pensais qu'il allait tomber dedans
parce que là il ya un coût évident pour
les blancs qui se fait ramasser par une
alors pour les blancs on envie de jouer
d'un mach 4 par exemple pour menacer h7
le wallon ses tours ses six mais on a
envie de jouer tour c'est si c'est si ça
semble puisque le fou près forge et la
dame bien peu déstabilisé effectivement
donc causé 6 c'est joli voilà la
réplique
il ya une réplique cavaliers deux échecs
ou d'un processus d'ailleurs les deux
cavaliers de vie chikhaoui magnifique tu
avais vu ça j'ai compris donc s'il vous
prend la tour est en prisme et si tout
prend même la torah 2 qui fait maths
auj jolie et une fourchette 3 tours si
fixie laura bush
on prend la tête avec échec ce qui fait
qu en prada et après une jatte à noël à
huy et donc il n'est pas tombé dans un
piège
non or c'est dommage nous attendait là
bah ouais je l'attendais tu vois la
force
il a poussé h4 pour éviter les macbook
oui alors oui et j'ai vu là jusqu où
j'étais devant l'échiquier il a joué h3
voilà il n'a pas lâché la pièce
évidemment une joue en h4
oui parce qu'aussi fait h3 je jouais à 6
et le cavalier lady g 5 n'a pas dit oui
c'est bizarre qu'il ait vu en jouant
quoi finalement c'est dire mais non vous
le métrage quatre pions et leurs
histoires de l'erreur avec le roi il ya
vu une variante aussi que j'ai pas
regardé avec l'ordinateur un plus tôt
dans la partie et enfin bon on va
continuer comme ça on est h4 ben là il
ya fou 17 empêche les coûts des sites et
ses 6 et puis ça fait une menace
imparable alors ça menace face à
contrôler cas cécilia plus jamais tous
ces sites mais sa menace trouver celle
là il peut pas et on voit la tour parce
que effectivement la tour sied bien en
c3 mais simplement d'un bac de cap et a
pas de case c'est incroyable piège de
tout en fait c'est rare d'attraper un
pour voir ces problèmes résultent du
fait que la dame blanche est en jeu
c'est vrai quelle heure exactement donc
fausse 17 c'est très fort là les blancs
les noirs ont pris avantage parce que
y'a un problème c'est tout alors
qu'est-ce qui la joue ici il a joué h 5
fu bessin qui continue maintenant quand
même fou des sages et la salle la
déstabiliser bon il très mal il perd les
qualités sophie pour prendre cette voie
il a fait tourcoing saint geours un
pédibus à tout pour nous c'est
intéressant quand même parce que oui les
premières quand même la qualité mais il
a récupéré le cuir c'est comme ça
pourquoi parce que si on suit tout
reprend avec la tourner séparer les deux
sens et bien on peut récupérer tout
reprendre la vallier et puis si on fait
dans cette tour
et bien moi c'est à la saison reprendre
quand même le cas variés et dans tous
les cas voilà et si on prend l'eau ici
on trouve c'est fou prend un tour mais y
aurait tout reprendre sa cèdent en
france n'est pas vraiment bon ça c'est
pas bon ça laisse des pieds sont prises
non j'ai pris de l'âge donc on prix de
l'acide échange les dames s'éprend ouais
c'était regagnant donc qui fait tout
reprend en espérant faire des maths
voilà ramener tout le jeu à l'endroit où
il a trois puis de quatre pièces on a
essayé de faire feu là j'ai fait un bon
goût parce que je voulais au début
fermathe mais ça marche pas si je joue
tour un point ces voyages deux mois
dames 1 il s'en sort par food et cinq
échecs
il menace mat 1 h 1 voit la fin du cycle
3 à 20 h 8 et la misère à la casse g3
part d'un f3 dames 11 3 ou dans le slot
même d'eric attias échange de la mairie
qui a été en moins je fais simplement tu
fais jamais froid je fais échecs et
leurs chiens ou angers
les rois g3 et là c'est pas clair du
tout il a d'ailleurs joué la demi heure
jeu il n'y a pas vraiment de la taxe sur
leur roi blanc et montre au prince à ce
moment de la partie ce canton il faut
faire attention et donc tu tombe pas
dans ce piège
j'ai bien joué j'ai joué tout repenser
devant la simplement tu god le pion à
tranquillement tout reprend ces deux là
il a joué il a joué damas fille 4 je
crois j'ai fait des 9,6 il a fait fou
des cinq échecs eschyle quand même j'ai
fait roi quid et là bizarrement je crois
qu'il a fait travailler le set non il ya
eu un coût avoisinant il a joué cavalier
je crois qu'il a fait voilà il a non
parce qu'il a fait cavalier recettes
après j'ai joué h6 donc là il a fait un
autre coup envie qu'il a fait des quatre
îles afin d'écarter quatre d'accord oui
en afrique asa la dame
effectivement c'est pas plus bête si un
gymnase échange la faillite et
reviennent en f3 bon ils perdent en
finale et peut sans doute perdante
les narines avec la vie propos qu'à
lille est tout reprendre en va en
prendre à prendre
fou de plus il a fait g4 encore bien
trempé jeu tour c'est un échec
3h de nos psys vient en g2 il ya des
hommes des cinq échecs ou fous ces six
échecs dames dessert
c'est quasiment match au ccg commission
alors d'amd 5ème dan dessin et menaces
tourache un drop la dame s'il fait davos
est il des amateurs de conte cité dames
cette île et matt par da machin on
survit tour g on regarde d'un mach est
un guichet où je prends et simplement
touché en matinée
donc s'ils menacent un signal à il a
joué f3 gagner une menace de maths qui
par la menace par f 3,3 j'ai fait un
coup méchant pour lui ces dames des six
oui ah non pardon j'ai fait non non
excusez moi j'ai fait tour ces deux
échecs
d'abord pour ces deux parce que s'il
vient sur la première rangée je fais
dame prend b3 et le il est mat civi en
bas d'en prendre deux trois menaces
mateja bah y'a rien de lui un échec en
des huit mais je fais royal cette étude
il ya peu de déchets donc là il était
obligé de faire rage et 3 passes aussi
fait 3h troyat fou est un échec il faut
enfin chez moi j'ai trois tours chez
nous voilà
et ouais donc croire madame des systèmes
peut jouer aussi fois je crois non
c'était moins clair parce qu'il avait
tout reprendre 5 1 il ne croit s'échappe
paraître 4
mais tours angers 2 pour f4 d'en prendre
des quatre matches sans risque ou non
mais alors peut-être qu'il peut laisser
faire une découverte
si vous êtes la menace tour j'ai deux
voies la tour point f5 pour preuve cinq
et billy mat
non parce qu'il peut jouer roi alors
elle fut calculer alors est ce que tous
ses protégés chez lui oui c'est vrai que
c'est pas clair et oui oui si on fait
tout ranger 4 d'objets de 30 du roi mais
ya rien est ce qu'on peut pas compris
mon regard des noms ouais c'est pas
grave j'ai bien joué je crois là la tour
d2 par mois un peu compliqué j'ai joué
c'est dante 6 il est complètement
paralysé après ça d'ici là des clous et
sa dame n'a pas d'entrer dans le combat
noire simplement tu cloud la tour il
peut rien jouer d'autres que j'ai
prélevé cinq oiseaux ou g5 mais c'est
pareil j'ai point f5 et là j'ai un
abandon après tout est simplement là
maintenant choisi et là c'est fini parce
qu'il n'a pas la place de quatre voies
l'appui aux projets de l'échec l'a
découvert ça sera le monde la colonne g
sans trop de dégâts et puis
même s'il donne la dame contre les deux
pièces il peut pas parce que
effectivement quand il prend le foot par
la tour donc grimper steven davantage de
pièces d'un compte retrouver si bien
défendu quand même
ouais mais surtout il a évité le piège
la tour c 6 il a vu les tactiques fort
que 1700 mois exactement
donc après ça donc j'ai averti
parce que j'avais un pour une vie
d'avant avant dernier rang dont la
dernière en attente pour la donc content
alors là oui je suis très content
nicolas parce que j'ai réussi la
difficulté je te disais tout à l'heure
quand il y en a beaucoup de points elo
de plus que l'adversaire c'est de ne pas
jouer trop vite
tu vois l'état des coups légers avec
cette confiance comme jouer sur sa force
sinon la différence de malassan se verra
pas vraiment super en défense en
attendant souvent à penser que c'est
facile que la position et gagne en
talents s'est jamais sciemment la menace
c'est de faire des gaffes en jouant trop
vite et voilà donc double titre de
champion de france vétérans alors
pourquoi pas plus de toute la collection
maintenant ça te fait quatre titres
nationaux
un merci beaucoup dit paula de passer
sur un plaisir diagonale tv comme à
chaque fois c'est quand on évoquait ce
n'est pas le point fort c'est sur la
lésion merci et merci de nous avoir
suivi sur des modèles tv au revoir à une
prochaine et sur des moules à bientôt